canal aurora is with us by the way
follow canal aurora
give people your social media it's uh
all day kca
all day kca is that everywhere is that
on everything it's on it's on
twitter it's on q anon it's on instagram
instagram
it's the website it's everything 4chan
yeah
fundamentalist.com i'm everywhere
hilarious comedian
started started with me um you know we
were like
like i was going to say thugging it out
i don't know why
it out means but we were at open mics
in 2010 yes late 2010
yes i met you i was doing my first set
ever at which i might have done better
than tonight
i'm kidding i love new york uh
it was i was at a coffee shop in long
island called wild child slash
tattoo parlor tattoo parlor yes right
you'd bomb and you'd hear the needle
buzz you you hear whenever you bomb
it's just a guy going oh yeah okay and
they were all going to like get their
like they'd get like some chick's name
tattooed on them right that tattoo shop
did a lot of like
like uh like whatever what is the term
when you like turn one tattoo into
another one
a transformation maybe i don't know it
was a lot of names being changed yes
and dogs faces because i it was a lot of
dogs but i remember there was always
like a consultation yeah
like we would be like we'd walk in and
we'd see somebody and they'd be like
okay so here's what we could do
and say you made a mistake here's what
we could do we could turn your
ex-girlfriend's name
into r.i.p and a nice 911.
you could do like an r.i.p right the
heroes right
towers and they're like okay i
constantly heard from those
tattoo chairs you know this is permanent
now you know this is permanent right you
know you can't walk in here tomorrow
and get rid of this and by the way they
should like that was such a
a weird eerie thing for us to hear doing
stand-up comedy because it's like oh
[ __ ] this is permanent
yeah for a lot of us it was permanent
and um i was doing my set and it was
like whatever dumb
i could all have like a little net book
yes i remember that yeah it was a little
like a net book
right and you were like typing on it and
every now and then i would say something
funny and he'd go
huh he'd have like a little like huh
yeah it was and then and then i was
because
i was a guy i was like one to like like
impress and then there was another guy
with a scot right who ideally didn't
want to impress
he gave me a fake name yeah the first
time i met him
what what did he he's like my name is
michael and i was like this is i'm gonna
know this man for the rest of my life
yeah i'm livid
why why did he do that i don't know he's
just a weird you know scott's a weird
guy he's an audience he's a great guy
i love him but he's nuts but i remember
that that was the beginning of and then
the canal like we would go into the city
and like do
stand-up comedy at these crazy places
yeah i started doing this thing called
trip
sunday yes and you would take two comics
i would take two comics with me
so it would be three comics three mics
uh one day basically a hundred miles of
driving and it was usually me you
dennis yeah yeah it would be i would
alter it always switch around switch
yeah cause sometimes you might be booked
sometimes sometimes you're like you know
what man i don't want to eat my
[ __ ] ass three days three to three
mikes in a row
that was a great day of comedy yes
because it was we did a a hipster mic
yeah a black mic yeah and then uh long
island
club mic sad mind
it would yeah would always end good or
bad at a pizza shop across the street
yes
eating eating a couple slices and one of
the saddest moments and i
want to let you tell the story because
you remember exactly how it happened
right
was the night you decided you had to
move into new york city
so we're doing it's like another trip
sunday i mean there's a hundred miles of
driving
for one day it's a lot yeah because we
would start in long island or i'd pick
you up
yes or you'd come to my mom's place and
then we shoot into the city
yeah we do these mics we're fine if
trying to figure out parking
trying to get to these things and then
uh then shoot out to long island and not
like
regular not like you know a simple like
new hyde park
right there we're talking in there deep
deep huntington
yes yeah so and it's not every day would
everything work
in fact most of the times it wouldn't
right you're just eating it all day long
so this day
nobody's happy yeah we're all we're in
the car we're
now in deep long island huntington we
had bombed at the hipster mike
yes bombed in the black room yes yes now
we're heading back home
right and we're now at this mic in
in huntington it's a second floor it's
this place it was called chesterfields
yes yeah and it was like it had some
history to it but nobody knows
nobody knows the history but everyone
always said you know this place is known
i think they used to say eddie murphy
started here if you started yeah
no one knew what that meant i think
eddie murphy took the bus that passed by
there i still have no idea what that
meant
no clue but people be like have some
respect and murphy started here yeah but
like you should they have a picture and
it's a white guy named eddie murphy yeah
yeah by the way these are the most
racist people in america
telling you that eddie murphy started
that right i'm like you're a
insanely racist person like you know
they're just taking pride in the
accomplishments of it like there's a
picture of any murphy but there's racial
epidemics
he's scrawled on the glass eddie murphy
started here he should have stayed here
like okay so we're we're sitting there
and uh i'm sitting next to you and we're
just watching people go up
yeah and then a guy gets up
and he is a rodney dangerfield
impersonator yes
as to why you need to do rodney's
material at an open mic right beyond me
yeah
it's already tried yes yeah he did it on
letterman
right i mean you know what i mean he did
it you're not working anything out
yeah you're right yeah it's like why do
you need to retry material on
carson does that get no respect work yes
yeah this is for your audience it does
for whatever birthday party has hired
you yeah
yeah this is gonna be fine who quality
controls rodney dandrickville's material
but the guy's up there he's got the suit
he's got the tie
yeah he's shaking the tie i got no
respect yeah
and then you hear somebody yell from off
stage
what the [ __ ]
and we look over because we're like this
is an open mic nobody should be heckling
right it's art it's mostly comics anyway
yeah and we look over and
by the door is another rodney
dangerfield impersonator
dressed in a suit and red tie
going you stole my act
in complete earnestness yes no to the
extent to which this is not a joke
yeah that it was not that no one
appreciated this in any in a comedic way
at all
so what the [ __ ] was genuine he was
shaken to his core he walked into a
rodney
he saw the other one and was like what
the [ __ ]
and he goes he yells from off stage just
because i had a heart attack
you think you can do my act yes
which is rodney's act whatever right
and and i lean over to you and i just
whisper
i'm moving next week i move to the city
so first of all the rodney one riding
gets off
the next rodney yeah then like they let
him go up like
right after right right right because
he's like upset
yeah and he does look sick
he's not done
he had legitimately suffered a heart
attack he was
like in recovery for a cardiac incident
it was not good
he cuts the line and he goes this is how
you do
it and does more rodney material and
then he goes like this
he goes he goes i'm here and he goes
i'm recovering from a heart attack i
don't know if i can still do this
and i just want to try this out because
that's the way i make money
yes and i want to know if i can still do
it she now has like the added pressure
of like
not lj and he wasn't that good no
no i could barely tell it was rodney
going to tell you right now doing a
rodney dangerously impersonation
yeah it's a young man's game it's not
it's yes
and by a young man i mean 40s yeah
yes yeah um and uh and then i was like i
gotta go and you were the first
um amongst us yes to have to leave
yeah i lived in an apartment in the east
village yes in alphabet city alphabet
city yeah cnn ninth
and you were the first one and i was so
impressed and everybody was like [ __ ]
he's doing it
yeah he's actually doing it right he's
actually leaving
he's not gonna have pizza with us
anymore no he's not
leaving and then uh and then you moved
right after i moved pretty soon yeah
yeah yeah
i moved pretty soon because i used to
hang out with you yes and i used to and
i'm like man
come on this is better right i just
realized it was better i'm like this
works
yeah this is what you we should have
been doing we were because it was easy
this is the thing this is the trap
it's easy to do open mics in long island
because you
drive to the thing yes you drive you
park your car
yes there's a parking lot yes and you
walk right in
right do your set and then you leave
right it's not like the city where
you're on the subway
yes you're someone is dancing in front
of you
yes and you're like i gotta make these
jokes work right and then you go mike to
mike to mike
it's not like that in long island you're
still the same person
yeah but you're just doing comedy yeah
that's the problem not you could still
work at verizon
right and do your [ __ ] yes so when
you make that
sacrifice to move into new york city
you're taking on a different identity
i had a conversation with some comics
and they're like what makes you a comic
a comedian
right and they're like is it money is
i'm like well i think that you got to
give up a certain amount
yes and that's what it is you're right
yeah and
a lot of these guys moved from other
places yeah here to do comments
it it has to be to me when i look at it
i don't think it's money
yeah to me it has to be the organizing
principle of your life
yes that's what i view it as right to be
a real comedian
yeah to be somebody who does comedy
whatever but if you're a comedian
to do it it's got to be the organizing
principle of your life meaning
i'm a comedian and these are the choices
i made
in pursuit of that you could make money
and it can still not be the organizing
principle of your life absolutely there
are people that we met in long island
you were just like
yeah this is what i get paid to do this
and you're like
who people pay for this we always knew
what we didn't want to be
yeah i think that's a great thing about
starting in long island right
listen i went back to long island and i
was at the diners there and i was you
know
showing my friends there and i'm like
i'm
really happy and listen i i love long
island yeah i grew up there
but i'm really happy i i got out of
there
yeah man i'm really when you go back to
those diners
yeah they stink they're horrible yeah
they're terrible and you know what it is
there's like four good diners in the
entire long island i mean
i think they all used to be better but
now it's just but you also look at the
people
right and you look at everything and you
go you know what i'm glad my journey was
out
right i'm glad my journey was out of
here absolutely
you know yeah